Charles and David Koch are two of the
richest men in the world each one of
them is worth tens of billions of
dollars some of their money is inherited
much of it they made themselves but to
their credit the cokes had never been
content merely to get richer they are
engaged intellectuals David a sincere
desire to change the world so for years
the brothers had been the single most
important funders of Republican politics
in Washington in the country Koch
network of donor spends hundreds of
millions of dollars every election cycle
virtually every major conservative
nonprofit in Washington takes Koch money
often a lot of it Coca organizations
train political organizers and
candidates many Republican lawmakers owe
their careers to the cokes and are happy
to say so for people whose main business
is making fertilizer and paper towels
the cokes have been remarkably effective
in American politics and not
surprisingly the left hates them for it
both the Koch brothers and their
families who by the way are very nice
people have been grotesquely and
repeatedly maligned by the media this in
turn has convinced many conservatives
that the cokes must be on their side
anyone who's been slandered by the New
York Times has got to be doing something
right that's the idea it's not a bad
standard but in this case in the case of
the cokes conservatives might want to
pause and rethink the relationship as it
turns out that cokes don't have much in
common
with conservatives they are in fact
totally opposed to most conservative
policy goals the cokes are libertarian
ideologues they're passionate and
inflexible about what they believe
America first the cokes find the very
notion of that absurd if not fascist an
economic policy that seeks to strengthen
families the cokes denounced that is
quote crony capitalism or picking
winners and losers they think it's
immoral and they'll tell you so
controlling our borders the cokes
consider that racist a few years ago in
fact Bernie Sanders noted that the Koch
brothers are far to the left of him on
immigration open borders quote that's a
coke brothers proposal Bernie Sanders
said and he was right but in fact it's
more than a proposal it's in effect what
we have now in this country open borders
and that's thanks in part to the cokes
the overwhelming majority of Republicans
want a secure border unless immigration
that's what
voted for Donald Trump two and a half
years later though the border is more
porous than ever a tide of humanity is
flooding in illegally Republicans in
Congress have done almost nothing to
help with the situation why well you can
thank the koch's for that in 2018 Koch
backed organizations the freedom network
and Americans for Prosperity pressured
Republicans in Congress to use their
limited post-election lame-duck session
to pass an amnesty for the so-called
dreamers going into this election the
2020 race a mysterion's the cokes top
legislative priority so if you're
wondering why the Republican Party often
seems completely out of sync with its
own voters this is why and it's not just
on immigration the Koch Network has also
successfully pushed Republicans to join
the left in going soft on crime the
cokes aggressively backed the first-step
Act which is currently allowing drug
traffickers to leave prison early they
support the sentence and sentencing
reform and Corrections Act that would
cut required penalties for heroin and
cocaine traffickers in half now keep in
mind they're doing all of this in the
middle of the deadliest drug epidemic in
American history the cops don't even
bother to argue that these so-called
reforms would help any law-abiding
American in any way they just believe
it's the right thing the libertarian
thing to do so they're pushing for it on
economics meanwhile you won't be
surprised to learn that the cokes hold
views that bear no resemblance at all to
what most Republican voters believe the
cokes have pushed for cuts to Social
Security to Medicare for example a vast
majority of Americans are opposed to
that most Republicans are opposed to
that like almost everyone else by the
way Republicans want lower drug prices
drugs are expensive been getting more so
and yet the cokes are working to kill a
bill introduced by Senators Josh Hawley
and Rick Scott they'll prevent drug
companies from charging Americans more
than they charged the people of Canada
or France that seems like a fair idea to
most people the cokes are preventing it
from happening then the cokes helped
draft the 2017 tax cut that turned out
to be a far better deal for corporate
America than it was for the American
middle-class a majority of Republicans
support capping interest rates on credit
cards in payday loans the cokes think
that idea is ridiculous
in fact some years ago when David Koch
ran for Vice President as a libertarian
abolishing all usury laws was part of
his platform
now there's nothing surprising about any
of this or illegitimate it's what many
rich liberals believe it's just not what
most Republicans believe and that's a
problem give that the cokes are the
single most powerful figures in the
Republican Party the cokes don't seem
interested in hearing you complain about
that or anything else actually
remarkably they have now joined the
left-wing campaign against free speech
in America next month the Charles Koch
Institute will hold a summit with the
anti-defamation league and executives
from major tech companies including
Pinterest Airbnb patreon Mozilla the
stated purpose of the meeting is to
formulate quote best practices on the
fight against hate and extremism online
end quote but you know exactly what that
really means
it means censorship of your views for
the left fighting extremism always
entails crushing normal conservatives
that's why pinterest has censored live
action it's why patreon banned Miley
innopolis it's why Mozilla drove out
Brendan Eich for the crime of donating
to the wrong political campaign big tech
has become a far greater threat to your
freedom than the federal government cops
don't care about that
nothing Google does violates libertarian
orthodoxy more to the point the cokes
don't care about Republican voters or
what happens to them okay that's fine
no law requiring them to care but then
why are they running the Republican
Party that's a question Republicans
should start asking themselves